tomorrow marks one week since a racist
mass shooting in buffalo 10 people were
killed till 10 families lives are
forever changed they will never be the
same
our next guest knows all too well what
they're going through nelba marquez
green is her name she lost her little
six-year-old daughter honor grace to gun
violence at sandy hook elementary school
it's been nearly 10 years ago now
marquise greene marquez green rather is
also a licensed marriage and family
therapist and she joins us now
it's really good to have you here at
nelma i'm so sorry it's under these
circumstances because every time
something like this happens
my first thought goes to you
because everybody thought when the new
town shootings happened finally this
will be the game changer finally things
will be different as we sit here close
to 10 years later we're still having
this conversation what goes through your
mind when you hear a story like this
we're going to continue to be here
unless we do things differently and we
have to find a way in the meantime to
support families so that's incredibly
important to me and the reason i'm here
you said most of the millions of dollars
donated after sandy hook did not go
directly to the families and you make
this distinction between reflexive
giving where people just want to help
and then reflective giving could you
expand on that i do it falls on the it's
the responsibility of the donor when
they want to support families to ask the
question and reflexive giving is exactly
that it says you know i just want to
give and you give and you don't ask
those questions you don't say where's
the money going who is it supporting we
want you to be reflective in your giving
we want people to understand that they
have to ask the questions if you want to
help a movement go ahead and help that
movement if you want to help a family
though you have to ask the questions
how do i do this
so um can you help
help us understand what life is like
after
the news coverage and the cameras go
away when the unspeakable happens yeah
in your life it's an everyday act of
faith it's an everyday act of sheer grit
and resilience because not only are you
trying to heal from your own trauma but
you are consistently bombarded with a
hundred plus lives per day lost to gun
violence some we don't hear about and
then some like the one we saw on sunday
which just bring you to your knees again
but you know what what i think about
many times
and when i think about you guys we all
cover the story it's big news for a week
maybe even two weeks maybe even three
and then we move away and i just think
about all the people that are left with
this big pile of ugliness and pain yeah
can you talk about that nobody sure
because people say time heals all wounds
not this one um
i would tell you that this is why we
need stronger communities this is why we
need attention on those families beyond
when the cameras leave so that doesn't
happen here but that does happen in
communities of support so we need to be
better at finding ways to support
families even after the cameras leave so
what is your message to those families
what are they going through
my message to those families is i know
you are hurting i know it feels like all
is lost but we need you to be here we
need you to be here for your families
and you deserve healing in your life um
those were the message that were most
salient to me and that's whether they
take action and engage in action or
whether they just want to heal their
families both of those are worthy and we
want you here for members of that wider
community that supportive community what
do you say to them how do they go knock
on a door offer their help how do they
phrase it what's the first step
you're never going to say the right
thing but we do need you to show up it's
something my son said to me my son said
to me i don't remember who was there in
in those early days i just remember who
showed up so we need you to show up in
the weeks after in the days after in the
years after it is still meaningful to us
when people remember and say i know who
you are i remember your daughter because
isaiah was at school that day that his
that his little sister was kid how old
was isaiah now isaiah is 17 doing well
he has a supportive community and anna
would have been would have been 6 16.
what did you teach isaiah after this
because there's so much conversation now
about hatred how this person this young
[Music]
hated so deeply did you have
conversations with isaiah about how to
move forward how not to hate
it's interesting to me
that a white young shooter killed my
daughter and yet we still looked at
isaiah and said
you can't hate anybody we will not allow
that in this home so it fills me with
rage as a mother that someone could be
out there not having that same
conversation with their child how dare
we as parents encourage or allow for our
kids to pick up these hateful message
that will then cause what we saw the
events of this weekend it is not okay
and we can do better we must do better
yeah speaking of race you know your
daughter was a child of color and you
said if the shooting happened somewhere
else she might not have received the
same type of coverage
how does race play a role when we have
these very tragic incidents in our
country it plays a role in how we report
the incident it plays a role in where
our empathy is after the incidents it
plays a role in resources empathy drives
resources so if you feel like oh well
that was just on a street corner they
were probably doing something wrong
you're not going to send a teddy bear
right but in newtown everybody sent
teddy bears so we need to grow in our
capacity for empathy for all families
impacted by gun violence wow
noble marquez green thank you so much
for coming today thank you powerful
thank you thank you again i'm so sorry
we we're still having this conversation
close to 10 years later but we'll never
forget your daughter me too thank you